[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very excited to be talking about
cautious capitalism for our second round
with Alexander makovan hello hey thanks
for having me back
I'm so excited thank you for coming on
we have a lot to catch up about over the
last year it's been since we had our
first conversation you guys can find
that on our channel so as a dono
Alexander makovan CEO of conscious
capitalism which is dedicated to
elevating humanity by improving the
practice and perception of business and
you can find the links in the bio below
to conscious capitalism org as well as
the Twitter profile conscious cap Alec
so start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask her yes
what are your thoughts on the direction
of our world I think it's easy for
people to focus on the negatives today
especially because they make the
headlines of the news so frequently but
overall I'm optimistic about the
direction of our world we're living in
the best period to be alive in human
history people have longer life
expectancies higher quality of life
access to more opportunities were
actually on the verge of eliminating
extreme poverty in our lifetimes and
it's all because we have more
opportunities to collaborate with
interact with and build things with
other human beings that we've never seen
in human history before so there
challenges facing the world there's a
ton of work for us to do but honestly
I'm optimistic about where we're going
because the potential for us to address
those problems is greater than ever
before and how do we most optimally work
together in the globalized 8 billion
human geopolitical climate on tackling
these problems
through free exchange of ideas and
activity between individuals this isn't
something that is simplified or easily
planned from the top down the world is
so complex nowadays we need more
opportunities for people to interact
with one another to collaborate to
explore new ideas to build new things
together new businesses with one another
that are going to tackle the problems
that we're facing today and the problems
they're gonna come up in the future and
there's an opportunity for us to lean
into that and to do so in a way that
from an elevated perspective in a way
that I don't think we've ever seen in
human history before so when humans meet
to around the world to creatively
endeavor into projects together that
acts as like we're running tons of
different permutations of ideas
collaboratively together and what would
be the best way to enable that free idea
flows free markets to pursue equal
degrees of economic freedom how do we
get to those things so you hit the nail
on the head there it's the free flow of
ideas and free markets for people to
interact with one another and this is
giving away my bias but it's I here at
conscious capitalism because it's
correct
we need more conscious capitalism we
need more people to understand how
capitalism and business are
fundamentally human endeavors they're
about
people serving other people and that at
their root capitalism and business are
good ethical noble heroic in that free
market capitalism has been one of the
greatest ideas humanity has ever come up
with and if we lean into it the right
way building businesses on concepts like
higher purpose and stakeholder
orientation we are going to unleash the
potential of humanity in ways that we
can't predict right now higher purpose
inclusive stake holding these types of
things yeah yeah yeah and then and then
what is a let's let's get into kind of
like a bit more weed
a lot of our episode on the mission last
time and what's happening but we're
gonna do a big update on what's been
happening let's get a quick bit on the
on this people serving other people on
the mission and the ethos of conscious
capitalism so conscious capitalism is a
way of thinking about capitalism and
business that emphasizes the human
nature of these endeavors and it
encourages businesses to run on four
tenets to fulfill that potential of
being a human centric endeavor having a
higher purpose than just maximizing
profit stakeholder orientation finding
win-win-win solutions for every one of
business impacts rather than
prioritizing one group above another
conscious leadership moving past just
analytic or even emotional intelligence
and getting to systemic and spiritual
intelligence where business leaders
embody the values of their company in
their daily lives in their activities
and conscious cultures where people are
able to bring their full authentic
selves to work every day to not only put
up with but become even more inspired by
their work and contribute to their
activities in a more meaningful way mmm
so okay let's let's unpack a little bit
so we're we're trying to identify what
our North Star is what gives us the most
meaning and purpose in life and usually
the more that we align that with some
sort of a selfless endeavor of serving
other people providing civilization with
value or families with value or
communities with value these types of
things the more it is that we feel like
a more divine potentially alignment with
with source or spirit and all right now
and it's not just design please there's
something called the happiness paradox
in philosophy where if you want to be as
happy as possible the worst thing that
you could do would be to make decisions
based on what's going to make you happy
if you do that for a weekend you're
gonna be pretty miserable at the end of
it you're gonna be rundown tired and
regret some decisions but people who put
their own happiness to the side they
don't make it their end they adopt
something else as their higher purpose
whether it's their family their
community of
principal and I deal those people happen
to become the happiest individuals in
the world so it's not that happiness or
profit or bad things but that adopting a
higher purpose than those actually is
what life is all about and oh that
should be our goal and if you do that
here's the here's the benefit you're
actually going to be happier you're
gonna make a greater profit as a
business then if you were to set those
as your goals and make your decisions
based on that yeah yeah yeah that's that
that inclination towards towards sir
being in service to others is seems to
be one of the most important callings
for a higher purpose period and I love
that one and then also case within um
stakeholder orientations what you call
it I like to think of it as inclusive
stake holding let's talk about maybe
what this could evolve to be like how
similar they are on an inclusive stake
holding basis it's so much about like
one of the models that Silicon Valley
started to do in the right direction was
that employees gained ownership of stock
of the company so that moves is someone
in the right direction now I think where
it's moving even further is where the
where the company is is based so like
uber or Twitter or right here in
downtown San Francisco well what about
the inclusive stake holding of the city
with the company like why is the company
not why is a city not a shareholder in
the company why is there not already a
better social fabric designed around the
city with the company in it also things
like all the people the customers so
like the fact that we each take a
hundred plus uber rides let's say a year
for that our customers of this company
well why can't we each gain a very small
token of shareholder ship every single
time that we take a ride with the
company because we are the ones that
help to build the value of the
organization so what are your thoughts
about something like that moving in
towards that inclusive stake holding
future so I like the term inclusive
stake holding I think it that sounds
very aligned with our stakeholder
orientation term
let me give some background as to where
we come from with this which i think is
going to lead me to a very different
conclusion from you actually Oh
interesting so the biggest problem with
the conversations around stakeholders
and shareholders is that most of the
time people bring into it a fixed
mindset or the idea that this is a
zero-sum game the only way you benefit
shareholders or you benefit customers is
to take from someone else you have to
take from the employees you have to take
from the suppliers and that's the only
way you're going to lead to greater
returns for investors or that customers
are gonna get cheaper or better goods
that's the wrong mindset that's
fundamentally antithetical to what
business is all about which is a
positive sub game where you get better
because I get better we serve each other
and we're both better off for the
transaction somehow that's been lost in
the theory around shareholders and
stakeholders and conscious capitalism is
bringing us back to the idea that you
can find win-win-win solutions that
benefit every stakeholder group and
that's the mindset that business leaders
need to go into their activities and
even the really difficult decisions with
so what this actually does is instead of
elevating the role of shareholders it
actually emphasizes that that's just one
group amongst many that the business
impacts including the community the
environment employees and customers so
rather than asking how do we get other
stakeholders to become shareholders I
actually think it's important for us to
ask why is there this aura this mythical
status around shareholders and
businesses today rather than a deeper
appreciation for the other stakeholders
that our business impacts and the
interdependence between what they do in
shareholders such that we understand
that businesses are a nexus of contracts
and agreements and you need to give as
much credence to the other stakeholders
as he do to shareholders
yeah I dig that I dig that too yeah this
is there's so much good overlap with
where we're looking at at heading and
what we're discussing here what's been
happening in the last year with the
momentum so is this right that normally
organizations reach out to conscious
capitalism learn about the ethos learn
about how they can start implementing
some of the practices to become more
consciously aware themselves as
businesses that's usually what the
trajectory is that's right and it's more
than that though it's also as a
philosophy for business something that
businesses express interest in or that
they start to advocate themselves even
as they're going down this journey and
what we've seen over the past year is an
incredible uptick in interest in
conscious capitalism at every level from
startup businesses to some of the
largest companies in the most
influential investors talking about
conscious capitalism and as the way of
the future to give just two examples
conscious capitalism was offered at the
Milkin conference this year has the
solution to the challenges facing
capitalism today then Larry Fink the CEO
of Blackrock the largest and that
investment platform in the world has
said on CNBC we need more conscious
capitalism in the world they're getting
on the bandwagon with this there is so
much momentum carrying this forward and
it's such a contrast from where things
were a decade ago when this idea was met
not only with skepticism but too rigid
to a certain extent that thinking word
to the next 10 years I think we're gonna
move past just the inspiration or the
exploration of this to a strong
community of practitioners of conscious
capitalism sharing their best practices
building one another up and making this
the norm we're conscious capitalism is
going to become redundant and the what
way that people just think talk and act
within capitalism mmm-hmm
the new norm yeah yeah so well what does
it look like when a an organization
comes on that says massive as like
Blackrock or like that's as small as I
cam on table business like what would be
the differences for being able to
leverage conscious cap
it's good a very company to company
because it's not just their size it's
also where they are on the journey some
businesses are coming in because they
know they're not conscious right now
they don't have a higher purpose beyond
just making a profit that's all they've
been doing for generations perhaps or
they know they're prioritizing one
stakeholder group above others and it's
harming certain individuals we get
businesses that come in like that where
they act maybe they have a new CEO or
someone who's been around for a while
says we need to change and so we start
by just introducing them to the
community other business leaders that
they can learn from get inspired by and
take ideas back from and then as they
get more interested in this we introduce
them to more best practices and
opportunities we have learning and
development workshops courses and site
visits where businesses can take their
leadership through to understand how to
put this into practice and then we build
them up so that they become effective
practitioners and keep working on that
for other businesses they're pretty far
along already they're what we call
unconscious conscious capitalists where
they say this is what we've been doing
for generations we've just never had a
word for it or we called it something
else and when they come into the
community they've already got examples
that we want to share with others so we
are going to introduce them as a model
that other people should look up to and
that we want to use to inspire people
outside of business to appreciate the
role of capitalism and to go into
business themselves to make the world a
better place
so it's about meeting them wherever they
are on this journey so there's tons of
like workshops site visits these types
of things and also that it's fun hearing
when people come on and they're saying
things like we have been doing stuff we
just haven't had the word for it that's
that's great so yeah this is that
awakening that's happening to evolution
that's coming together and then what are
the best practices that are being shared
across the businesses so it varies and
each business is putting their own
practice out there so I'll give an
example that was highlighted at our
annual conference a month and a half
there's a company called talavera day
based out of Phoenix Arizona
they established call centers to support
some of the biggest companies in the
world and they source the majority of
their employees from incarcerated women
whoa they they are looking to not only
provide high quality service at their
call centers they're creating
opportunities for women who have been
convicted of crimes and most likely
based on statistics if when they leave
prison if they're not given the
opportunity to develop new skills or to
have employment potential after they
leave are likely going to engage in
recidivism yeah they create
opportunities for these women to develop
new skills to prepare for the workforce
and give them a give them a substantial
wage while they're still in prison so
much so that actually twenty five
percent of the women that start working
for televator while they're there would
stay with the company after they leave
prison and where we're in the process of
sharing their practices with other
companies in the network because when we
featured them at our annual conference
they highlighted so many businesses how
easy it is to forget about that about
women and or anyone in this situation in
your hiring practices if you're not
reflective on it do you have a box that
asks the question are you a convicted
felon most businesses do and they simply
move those resumes to the side don't
give them a second look is there a way
to establish a relationship with a with
a prison in their area to provide
workplace reentry there are lots of
opportunities like that available that
telomere is sharing with the conscious
capitalism Network now is this part of
the private prison business model I mean
are they also involved in no this is
something entirely different they're not
running prisons at all they're working
with inmates and prisons to provide them
with employment there and prepare them
for employment afterwards so then this
is so cool that you can do something
like where normally you would get people
that leave the prison system
such a high chance of recidivism and you
can help be that that pillar that is so
needed in people's lives of you what are
you walking out of the prison you have a
work opportunity that that pays well
gives you some meaning that starts you
on a path that's away from going right
back to prison
falling into the same traps I love that
that's a really powerful best practice
that's absolutely right
yes stuff like that's so cool give us
another highlight from the from the
conference that was that just happened
so this was actually a theme we also had
Johnny Scholl the CEO of the Society for
Human Resource Management talking about
the need for us to provide more
opportunities for inmates to enter the
workforce again in an important way but
we also actually had as we had other
speakers that were highlighting things
like need for more conscious capitalism
in the world of finance which is
something that hasn't been addressed
nearly enough Ron shake one of our new
board members is the former CEO and
founder of Panera Bread incredibly
successful company he wanted the game of
public of public corporations Panera was
a public company for a long time before
he actually decided to take it private
again just before he stepped down as CEO
because he started to see the challenges
that the company was going to face in
the long term in the public markets
short-termism
activists investors the ended and the
threat to their core values as time went
on rather than as compared to if they
were privately held where they were able
to think more long-term they're able to
take care of all of their stakeholders
in a way that's lined with their core
values and so fulfill their higher
purpose and there's a real challenge
right now for public businesses in
particular but really any business and
thinking through how it raises capital
to make sure that it's incentive
structure is aligned with its higher
purpose and what it's trying to fulfill
because if unconscious capitalism meets
or if conscious capital meets
unconscious finance it's a real
challenge for conscious capitals
when to be perfectly honest so we need
conscious finance with conscious
callosum so we absolutely do so what
would it look like like what does the
conscious finance company look like it
can come in a number of different ways
it could be that it's an evergreen and
outside investor where they plan to
never sell their investment and so the
company knows they're able to look
long-term could be family owned so that
you know that you've got people who are
committed to its values could still be
entirely owned by the founders or a
small group of investors that makes
total sense the coop model very coop
model as a possibility you could even
have a public company that's established
as a B Corp to provide a greater
protection for the businesses higher
purpose there are different models being
developed right now for this the one
thing that we know is what unconscious
finance looks like which is just pump
and dump strategies for reason for
funding for companies especially with
short-term traders that are looking to
just get as much money off of the stock
and extract value instead of finding
ways to create value with the company
yeah and then um you mentioned B Corp
thoughts on B corpse good stuff great
organization and movement that's very
aligned with conscious capitalism we we
are very good friends with one another's
organizations a lot of businesses are
overlapping between both there it's
another layer of protection if you go
through the legal process with B Corp to
take the higher purpose of a business
and write it into the bylaws and provide
protection in case you do face activist
investors short-term fingers people that
don't want to maintain those principles
as a business grows and evolves as its
necessarily going to yeah I think this
might be one of the first times where
I'm actually more consciously realizing
that investing in finance into
businesses is like really opening up a
very sacred door you have to be very
careful with where the money comes from
that gets financing the business who and
their ethics that are how aligned are
they with your ethics of the business
auto service is a very sacred
relationship it's a marriage really be
as your intertwined with them for the
rest of your life
if you do it for better for worse
through sickness and health for richer
for poorer that's what you're committing
to when you take on outside capital and
you can find the perfect match that
you're going to be happy with the rest
of your life or you can find a miserable
relationship that you're going to
regress of optimal stuff and then this
is also very true for the employees of
the companies as well that it's so
important to treat them with a most
optimal dignity the greatest amount of
value for them to feel like they
actually have meaning and a say in the
direction of how things are operating
from highest efficiency because we
actually when we talk to Rory Bronfman
his idea of if inclusion in the
workplace is like do you want to know
what's happening at the edges of the
company because usually what's happening
is someone that's like maybe a custodian
at like a Panera Bread could maybe tell
you about me give you some unique piece
of advice about what they're finding in
the garbage that can then spark you to
realize oh we need a different maybe
biodegradable or why are we throwing
away such an excess amount of an
individual item in the store these types
of things so you the custodian in this
case would need a very direct way to
talk to the management team in order for
the information actually be communicated
so these are the interesting things that
can happen when we have an inclusive
workplace we have an inclusive stake
holding system when we're providing more
value than we're extracting all these
types of things so um how do we what
what do we do with like all these things
kind of seem like they're pointing us in
the direction of of like getting further
away from self dealing and more towards
that inclusive stake holding the
inclusive fitness era conscious
evolution towards what capitalism may be
like a conscious capitalism the next
generation is like a 2.0 around the
world could look like what are some of
the yeah go where no one has gone before
exactly that's exactly what we're doing
yes
yes and now where does something like
weird of something like a
decentralization the protocols of
decentralization where do they fit into
the conscious capitalism movement so in
within a business that's where you start
to think about your culture and how you
make sure that people are empowered
within it and decentralizing
decision-making to such a level where
they are able to have a voice they're
able to contribute in a meaningful way
such that you are allowing them to
really be human in their work rather
than a Tama Don's as well as more
effectively and efficiently contribute
to the organization's activity if you're
outside of that then it is asking
ourselves how do we share these best
practices how do businesses connect with
people in a more decentralized manner
and the opportunities are tremendous
right now this is at one of the reasons
why businesses need a higher purpose and
need to be more authentic in what they
do think less about marketing campaigns
that are removed from what they
typically do and better represent who
they are fundamentally to their
customers because information is
decentralized nowadays the businesses
aren't in control of the narrative in
the way that they used to be 50 60 years
ago they need they need to put out there
what they're doing so that consumers
know that they're being honest they're
authentic with this point otherwise
consumers future employees future
investors are gonna be able to call them
out on it right away
this is happening already in a
relationship of of an inclusive stake
holding with the technology like
potentially like a like a decentralized
ledger of what the company of the
relationship between the like give it an
example like a physician and a patient
where you only see them for 20 minutes
they're out the door you give them
whatever they need out the door versus
actually being able to slow down connect
with them and on a deeper emotional
level but also say that you know you're
not just giving them whatever and get
them out the door but it's more about
hey I'm gonna
time my stake as a physician into your
stake as a patient together and I'm
gonna give you an outcome here that's
going to propagate for the next one year
three years five years in your so my my
rewards are tied to your health being
most optimal things like that or a
teacher and a student is another good
example of that these types of things
how can we get more creative in the ways
that we support one another that's what
this is really calling for it's moving
past old models that are very
transactional one-off relationships
between individuals to recognizing our
interdependence and how when you benefit
I benefit in making that even clearer
developing the incentive structures for
it and being very explicit with that the
opportunity with the ledger is that
we're able to keep track of that more
easily than ever before and facilitate
relationships that didn't happen before
yeah it's fascinating what opportunities
are available to businesses now it is
yes yes
and now let's let's see let's explain
this point this geopolitically there's
there's like different experiments that
are happening with with what is an
optimal way for businesses to engage
with the government infrastructures and
engage with the people of the so there's
this kind of like how do these three
things play out so one of them is kind
of like the strategy of capitalism in
the United States with the democracy or
the representative democracy another one
is kind of like a stylized aisle of
governance and another example is where
we see like pushback in many ways of
like when capitalism kind of overreaches
too far the self-dealing overreach is
too far there's like an up evil of
socialism or communism but that actually
isn't as optimal as would be of
conscious capitalism came in to fix the
situation so tell us about what your
thoughts are like geopolitically around
the world with these different
experiments that are happening and is
conscious capitalism would you say the
most optimal or are there good things
from other places to take in as well
think so there are challenges in the
United States right now there's no
question about that
but especially when you compare the
American system and approach to evolving
the relationship between business and
government it's far it's it surpasses
and is in moving in the right direction
in a way that is in stark contrast to
say systems like in China or Venezuela
where you have more socialist or
communist systems and you see the
backlash against those systems coming
from the people themselves who see the
negative impacts of it on their daily
lives
whether it's the turmoil in Venezuela
that's been going on for the last
several months in really the last
several years or decades under 21st
century socialism there that's coming to
a head or the protest in Hong Kong right
now where the people want to retain a
level of independence and separation in
order to retain their liberties both
civil and economic and the challenge
going forward is is finding the right
relationship there in such a way that
people understand how business is able
to better their lives and is not self
dealing it's not a way to advance the
interests of a small group at the
expense of others especially utilizing
the government as a means to do so that
is one of the reasons that Venezuela has
been going through so much turmoil in
particular it did not have a conscious
capitalism beforehand which created the
backlash and the desire to experiment
with 21st century socialism and we
actually have entrepreneurs from
Venezuela who have fled the country who
are speaking at conscious capitalism
conferences about their experiences and
what they're seeing and are trying to
introduce a conscious capitalist
approach to the future of Venezuela has
the solution to their problems and in
fact are even saying that if we don't
get widespread conscious capitalism as
the next evolution of the economic
structure in Venezuela it will any
alternative to the socialism that
they've experienced for the last several
decades is going to be
lived there's going to be a backlash
against that afterwards there's an
there's not only a need for conscious
capitalism but honest but it's also an
opportunity for us as well though to
create an even better future because
it's not stagnant it's not static it's
something that we keep replenishing
re-envisioning and evolving going
forward to find a better way for us to
lead and work with one another to
elevate humanity through business and
let's do the environment as well because
this is a massive part of we come from
the same thing we come from nature from
source from spear we it nourishes us
every moment of every day with air with
food with water with all these basic
needs that we get to live with live from
and through with but at the same time
there's it's evident that we are in many
ways destroying the ecosystems there's
not a stake that the Eco that the
organization's have and the countries
have with the environment where we can't
destroy it along the way of maximizing
yeah well the environment is a
stakeholder - yeah how do you get
conscious capitalism strong footholds in
places like Venezuela when the level of
capitalism that's try to get a foothold
in Venezuela has all the guns
I I think that's something that we're
going to have to wait and see with
unfortunately now there are actually
some businesses that are already
practicing conscious capitalism in
Venezuela there are examples to point to
they're just not widespread right now
and we need to be supportive of those
businesses and examples so that there is
an opportunity for them to spread going
forward that and you you find examples
of conscious capitals everywhere in the
world in any kind of society we need to
tell their stories and we need more
people to know that they exist and there
is this opportunity for their society
going forward maybe that that's actually
the answer I want to give to your
question identify the conscious capital
thank you yeah who are they and yeah and
and and uplift them at greater extents
let's hit on environment so how do we
get the environment as an inclusive
stakeholder in the process the
environment has to be a stakeholder for
companies that are taking the
stakeholder orientation that that is
what that we are part of the environment
as you said we come from it it's the
source of everything that we do and we
need to make sure that as businesses
we're taking care of that in the same
way that we're taking care of other
stakeholders and that's going to be
different for different businesses but
it should be one of the challenges that
a business takes on for itself is there
any good code that we can take from a
because it seems like as we become more
aware as a species of the Anthropocene
of how we're affecting our environment
and how we can increase our awareness of
how to have inclusive stake holding with
each other and how to maximize each
other as well being that as that gets
lifted up as like let's say conscious
capitalism at the same time there seems
to be some practices that are also
really optimal for getting things done
in fast bits of time in places that have
maybe like a more authoritarian style of
moving so like we want to do something
we know we want to get it done we're
gonna dedicate a lot of our best
resources to it and it gets done
instead of has all like the chrony
corruption that that can occur that
hinders the processes do you think
there's good codes from maybe like the
Nordics or from China from other places
in the world some philosophies maybe
from Africa or from Southeast Asia that
that could be implemented into the
conscious capitalism ethos so the
conscious capitalism ethos is not an
American ethos I want very clear yes
totally this is a universal philosophy
that has its origins from spread out
around the globe that's actually to my
point that there are conscious
capitalists everywhere in every society
and this philosophy has been developed
in its own way by leaders across the
world it's important for us to draw from
the very best of conscious capitalists
everywhere not just in the United States
and that's even one of our emphases is
to make sure we're sharing the best
practices between them in their what
they're doing how they think about this
and utilize that as effectively as
possible yes do that in such a way that
we're not just saying we're gonna tackle
a single problem to the exclusion of
others we've this is such a complex
world nowadays we need multiple
strategies and solutions to problems we
need multiple perspectives taken into
account to ensure we're not ignoring
other stakeholders and bi and so by
trying to solve one problem creating a
dozen others at the same time that's
really that's so important with us and
why taking a stakeholder orientation
where you include the environment as a
stakeholder and find a win for that
while you're finding wins for your
employees your customers your suppliers
your investors and that everyone else
that you impact is so critical yeah yeah
and I see a you know around the world
that conscious capitalism bringing
itself up there's like examples of maybe
things like the future of sustainable
cities in places like Sweden that could
maybe be kind of like helped be brought
into like other conscious capitalists
around the world so it's kind of like
that is what I meant like kind of like
the transfer learning
from certain places into the yeah
absolutely
okay okay stuff like that okay because
it's it does at the end seem like moving
into the exponential technology age with
all of the the pressing issues that are
around synthetic biology or neuro tech
or super intelligence that this the race
to be the winners in these fields is so
financially lucrative that people will
be willing to take whatever means they
need to get to the end that is what
conscious capitalism is responding to we
can't we it's not sustainable for us to
live in a world where that is the
priority and it doesn't elevate our
existence to do so we should have
businesses that seek to thrive and
individuals who want to create
incredibly successful businesses but do
so for higher purpose and with
stakeholder orientation conscious
leadership and conscious culture
and then what another example of the
conscious culture from the organizations
that are currently at play around the
world within this cat conscious
capitalism ethos what are they doing
with the employees that they that they
have in their companies what is like one
of the main paradigms that they follow
with their employees one of the most
important things is to create an
environment where the employees feel
that they are trusted and support in
such a way that they can bring their
full selves and meaningfully contribute
to their work and that's accomplished in
different ways for different companies a
used car dealership based out of Texas
even as adopted that as its purpose
creating a culture of love and care for
all their employees for others it's
about so in facilitating transparency so
people know what's going on for others
it's about creating opportunities for
them of actually hiring anyone who is on
a list to give them a chance at life and
to give them a chance to support their
families
so it's expressed in different ways and
it's exciting to see all the different
cultures out there what's most important
for companies as they build this out
what role does United Nations or like or
like the use of psychedelics play in to
inspiring more conscious capitalists how
many people have said what's the role of
United Nations are psychedelics in this
one solution I don't I don't know how
many times that has been the combination
these are different but these are
different approaches to it some people
are incredibly inspired by the
sustainable development goals that the
UN has laid out and they're building
businesses around that some people have
used psychedelics and it's opened their
mind to a new state of consciousness and
they're beginning businesses that way or
people are changing because of it these
are different motivations and
opportunities for people to think
outside of the box and decide what
they're
purposes about and create businesses
built around that and that I think is
really exciting because you don't know
where someone's inspiration is going to
come from and we should embrace and lead
into whatever that source says for
people and they should lead into it
themselves they should explore the
different possibilities
to inspire them to give them their life
purpose so that they're able to build
businesses on purpose as well what do
you think happens when so many more
children are born into the world of a of
a more conscious capitalist world where
there's more degrees of freedom where
there's more creativity being unleashed
more purpose being fulfilled what do you
think happens in the next couple of
decades with that I think children are
gonna be a lot happier with their
parents who are more fulfilled from
their work and are better parents and
family members as a result of it I think
they're also going to grow up more
excited about going into business and
then actually become happy productive
businesspeople themselves as a result
because they see it as an expression of
who they are where we move away from the
nine-to-five drudgery thank God it's
Friday and no longer have to work
anymore to an integration of their lives
both as children and adults where
they're happy for work because they see
it as an expression of their purpose and
just what they want to do with their
lives yeah
okay I feel pretty good on what we when
we talk to them yeah yeah I feel pretty
good
what do you think how are you feeling
about the direction of the world after
this I'm feeling good I am feeling good
feeling very realistic there's lots of
things to yeah to do in order to get to
the world that we want to yeah that's
absolutely right none of this is a
shortchange the challenges before us or
the work that we're gonna have to do for
it but the opportunity is there for us
and we've got so many people who are
committed to making that happen
actually we we're talking before about
this great sign dreams don't work unless
you do and there are dreams out there
and there are a lot of people willing to
work for it now
and we can unleash that potential yeah
yeah and that creative potential is
going to end up pushing a lot of the
suffering out of the world is going to
end up increasing the amount of degrees
of freedom that people have it's going
to make our planet more sustainable for
generations to come so to unleash the
creativity is to solve the problems in
many ways that's exactly right okay and
let's let's wrap on a couple thoughts um
did we do you think that we did a decent
job on the update were there things that
you wanted to hit on that that we missed
on the update I think that's pretty good
actually
okay I could go through numbers and
stuff but that's boring for people so
which not are specifically sad just our
organizational growth but that's not the
interesting part it's the movement as
the examples I think I think we covered
a good was just the first conference
your leak on a couple years it's tough
to say actually because they've
redefined it this was maybe our ninth
annual conference Wow
yeah but you came on in 2014 2016 2016
okay
damn nine Wow and the organization's now
what a couple hundred t businesses a
couple hundred people people people we
have thirteen full-time staff but we've
got about three thousand volunteer
leaders around the globe we've got a
couple we've got about a hundred
businesses that are the most intimately
involved as our partners and many more
that are growing right now excellent
excellent excellent in the model is
usually they also help contribute to
your growth as like a nonprofit is that
what it normally is we're interdependent
absolutely these are partners with us so
that we support their activities to
implement conscious capitalism and they
support the growth of the conscious
capitalism yeah yeah okay
okay cool so 3,000 now volunteers that
are working if actually don't hold me to
that I'm gonna have to look at those
numbers but yes we've got several
thousand very actively involved members
of the community and off to check on
will on the numbers for volunteers cool
and who are some of the companies that
have signed on the last year that you're
most proud of so a lot of them are
mid-market businesses and I'm really
excited to have companies like laz
parking involved now they're one of the
largest parking companies in the United
States but they're just built on a
concept of love and their CEOs personal
story and why he went into business is
just so inspiring it's really cool and
we actually just got Mars signed on as a
partner in the last couple of weeks the
candy and candy company there are large
conglomerates of work in different areas
but they just have incredible and the
joy there they're delicious and they've
been run on core principles since their
founding that you know a long time ago
and work with their employees their
stakeholders their suppliers in
important ways and yeah exciting to see
them get on board more ethical ways yeah
because the way that we source chocolate
from around the world needs to be
ethically
yeah that's absolutely right stuff like
that yeah so getting them onto the yeah
conscious capitalism boat is awesome
okay let's see if you've updated any of
your answers since the last time I think
we've had some new questions - all right
let's do it what's your most
controversial belief nowadays I wouldn't
say it's a firm belief but that activist
investors are doing more harm than good
unpack a bit for us activist investors
more often than not are seeking short
term rewards they're not contributing to
value creation for the company they're
extracting value from it okay I used to
believe that activist investors were
good were good played an important role
in the market process to check
management and to ensure that a company
was being run the way that it should I'm
now much more skeptical of that and then
what do you think happens pre birth and
post death
I think we have energy and matter
constructed differently that's all do
you think we come from anywhere beyond
the 3d reality into these earth suits I
don't know I don't dream about the 3d
reality then we have lots of things that
exist that we that we know exist in the
world that are not part of 3d reality
like numbers and concepts and the
interplay between those things and 3d
reality is ever-present
so we're what we are in the concept of
the self that I think is a bigger
challenge that I don't have an answer
for but I I think that I think there's
so much opportunity for us to really
think through what it means for matter
and energy to exist before to exist when
we're live and just still exist even
after we die as we maintain that thanks
to the console off constant matter and
energy and then do you think we're in a
simulation
I don't think it really matters we might
be but doesn't really change what we're
going to do for the most part even if we
are you know what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
I remember that question from before I'm
pretty sure I said the same thing I'm
gonna say again it's love love is far
the most beautiful thing in the world
wherever you see it you smile and having
love is the greatest thing that one can
have
beautifully said Alexander thank you
welcome thank you he's so glad to be
here God now this is really nice
it's good to hear this update from you
thank you keep up this great work you
too this is a lot of fun we're all
exciting we're all we're all really
proud of what you guys are doing with
conscious capitalism Congrats and the
way you're inspiring other people around
the world to care about it and you're
getting these ideas out there this is
just such a great project thank you
thank you we're very grateful to hear
that thank you thank you and thank you
to those that watched we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode also go and check out conscious
capitalism or check out the Twitter page
go and share this more talk more with
your friends families co-workers people
online on social media about elevating
humanity by improving the practice and
perception of business around the world
conscious capitalism remember that
spread it share it let's do it everyone
and also shout out to round Vargas for
producing and directing thank you very
much Ron and also check out the links in
the bio to simulation support the
artists launch careers the organizations
around the world that you believe in
support us are our links below to our
patreon or PayPal as well as to our
cryptocurrency links are below and also
if you want to design cool merch like
this what's the most beautiful thing in
the world to get paid for the designs
and spread thought-provoking questions
that links below to our UB store and go
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
[Music]